hey I'm Mark Wahlberg and I'm going
undercover on the internet while I it's
actually me Twitter Leanne Duff wants an
open mark Whalberg actually do one-arm
pull-ups though I need to know I can do
a few one-arm pull-ups but I cannot do
like 50 straight one-arm pull-ups
without cracking a sweat or having my
voice changed at all like dusty did and
daddy's home
submitted Derrick Stephenson wants to
know does Mark Wahlberg age yes quite
rapidly actually I'm Mark Wahlberg I
know you're a busy man
but I was wondering if you could wish my
stepmom Jennifer a happy birthday she
absolutely loves you yes Jennifer happy
birthday happy birthday and happy
holidays Merry Christmas Happy New Year
best to you in 2018 more Robert any news
on the status of armored Wars movie ah
no no news of status yet still in the
works I'll give you an update as soon as
I have one soul blazer Instagram your
grandfather look good wearing that clear
quilted coat first picture that's
welfare old man they call will my
grandpa that's not nice
well it's a sweet sweet man he still
hasn't invited me to his house for
dinner but he's still kind enough to
work with me now three times so maybe
the one day I'll get that end by him
Yahoo Answers and Boogie Nights is that
really Mark Wahlberg's penis or just a
fake it was just a little fake for big
favor it's Mark Wahlberg in Pulp Fiction
what do you think that was the [ __ ] I
would have liked to have been in Pulp
Fiction probably not the [ __ ]
Sam Jackson oh man Sam is the best I'm
so good at being mean man you should
have seen when Sam what yelled at Will
Ferrell the first time on the other guys
oh my god I could thought laughing Will
was so scared I'm just trying to play it
off like he wasn't he was good [ __ ] of
Sam answers.com
whoa is Mark Wahlberg a jerk or is it
nice
he can't depends on who you ask I think
if you took a survey in this room
probably about 60/40 either way and if
the Patriots lose today yes I am [ __ ]
jerk Oh son dad Tom forgive me
the Mark Wahlberg singing rock star I
did singing rock star but they probably
replace my voice at times because
it's horrific we won't hear me really
saying listen to my failed attempts of
thing in Boogie Nights
that's me really singing and you could
also check out Eminem's new album the
song is called the heat he sampled me
and John Riley from Boogie Nights
actually a very good song read it my
favorite song by Eminem is drug bout and
he mentioned you in the saying back when
Mark Wahlberg was marking mark did you
actually Percy no lemonade if so is he a
cool dude
also after hearing that line it made me
look up to you I never made the
connection that that was you and the
other guys which is my favorite oh thank
you I hadn't met Eminem before he made
that song and then I met him at an MTV
event we hung out very cool guy very
talented and yes I didn't give him
credit for that a long time when I was a
hater
because he was a better rapper than me
home it I think that the first time the
public admitted that but it's pretty
obvious no I just posted that [ __ ]
Wikipedia to prepare for his role in
shoot Oh Wahlberg attended a long-range
shooting training at front sight
firearms training institute near Horeb
Nevada and was able to hit the target
eleven hundred yards on his second day a
feat which takes usually weeks to
achieve yes that is true that is a fun
fact I hit a target at eleven hundred
yards without sound like forty mile an
hour wind with a fifty caliber rifle so
what Quorra how do you get a physique
like a young mark wahlberg there's two
ways to do that most like they have to
be genetically born like that or you
have to be facing some serious
incarceration and know that you've got
to get in shape if not you're gonna be a
mark and not a good way how does mark
wahlberg produce such menacing facial
expressions you got to be born like half
shar-pei you know move all that floppy
skin around don't fall into the
hollywood traps of Botox answer
honey concept more evolved word to pitch
a movie script idea to him i live in
boston it would be perfect for the role
am i being typecast as a Boston guy
again anything scripts material send to
WME you can find up in my agent you
never know when the next great role is
going to come a great script so actually
uh
to leave no stone unturned so please
send it to me just go through the proper
channels don't pay somebody from Boston
who tells you they're gonna give me the
script if you give them a thousand
dollars it's not going to happen my job
is done thank you guys for your
questions